il donnait envie de voyager par les
papilles d'explorer le monde à travers
la gastronomie
anthony bourdain avait réinventé le
style des émissions culinaires sa mort
abrupte et imprévisible a créé un choc
chez ses confrères montréalais mais moi
jamais c'est une triste usa me fige et
complètement je trouve aujourd'hui c'est
un jour spécialement sombre de personnes
de nos confrères et un ambassadeur de la
cuisine ça nous arrache le coeur c'est
certain anthony bourdain été reconnu
pour son style décontracté dans ses
émissions il sortait les chefs de leur
cuisine aller à leur rencontre parlait
politique et société tout en découvrant
en nouveaux coins du globe
puis en 2011 le chef renommé débarque à
montréal
il invite alors le chef du toqué normand
laprise et martin picard du pied de
cochon a participé à sa virée dans la
métropole québécoise pour son émission
l'éleveur touristes ont le tournis y est
montréal tous les niveaux un poteau y
aller j'ai passé 24 heures avec une à
montréal c'est vrai 24 heures
j'ai promis des poteaux dire non non
c'est une journée extraordinaire monde
avec tuner ensemble ou une heure et
demie pour ne pas aussi la totalité de
la soirée party au lit et à brasilia 7
ans le soir puis je rentre chez moi à 16
heures du matin cet épisode fera
connaître montréal comme une destination
gastronomique importante et
incontournable en amérique du nord
anthony bordés en 2009 a vraiment donné
un gros coup de circuit
je dois dire parce que il ya dix
vraiment écouté il ya quelque chose qui
se passe ici au québec un petit vol
d'avion de new york chicago et on se
retrouve un endroit où on mange super
bien mais complexé la haute cuisine et
faire connaître des endroits à lille
mieux cachée du monde sait ce que ce
chef originaire de new york a fait au
fil des années récemment il a tourné un
épisode de sa série par tonne diffusée
sur cnn
à terre-neuve-et-labrador son personnage
public
irrévérencieux et bon vivant ne laissait
toutefois pas entrevoir sa détresse
ici elle couture radio canada montréal